two hello everybody it is Monday July
24th we are in summer it's official it's
hot
pretty much no matter where you are
it's gonna be hot but thank you for
joining us here today we got a great
week of Grace
week of shows
so I'm feeling still pretty bad sick
wise
Dan is sick as well you might yeah I'm
sorry bro if that was for me I apologize
although we were never really like mouth
to mouth at any point yeah unfortunately
that I remember hmm
but uh the good news is we're all yaked
up how much DayQuil you hit uh just just
a standard amount I I don't you didn't
rip it I don't abuse drugs
Ethan it's just DayQuil it's not even a
drug it's more like a sippy it's like a
juice it's a juice
that's just juice
well I got a bottle of DayQuil on the
way yeah we're shipping some more we're
doing a day call episode baby DayQuil
episode just kidding use only as
directed absolutely Always Forever
that's a joke we're not actually doing
that I've been snoring drain them all
day that I've not I would never never
recommend
um let's see
today
we're doing the sour challenge
we've done the chip
done defica we do the challenges I mean
what do you want we do five shows a week
we gotta do this [__] yeah yeah but
actually we're supporting the FaZe Clan
which is important to me phase the [__]
up
bro yeah
so this is this is FaZe rug thing love
for sure
yeah it's definitely phase Rock I'm not
sure if it's actually face technically
or not I guess that's pretty clever I
Gotta Give It Up to him yeah he moved
quickly and sour things oh he's a sour
guy he's the sour guy yeah blanks well
respect for that because I love sour
candy
try this he's smart did this did this
come after the spicy chip business yeah
I think so pretty smart guy move quick I
like that about him yeah
he's little but he moves fast he's very
little
my voice
um what else we got oh yeah I gotta get
out of here at 3 30 because I have a
call with my hematologist who's gonna
tell me if I'm dying of cancer or not no
no I'm only clapping
because I believe it's gonna be good
news that you receive kids they don't
seem not to I don't want to be over
dramatic nobody seems like super
concerned that I'm dying
yeah you mean the doctors like so I'm
not actually expecting a cancer
diagnosis yeah the doctors yeah I'm
pretty sure that they would be
pretty urgent about it wouldn't be like
I'll talk to you in a month right right
right
maybe he's a shitty doctor
maybe he's a fallen fan and he wants me
to die
I have a surgeon
um
but I am quite curious what's going on
there because
I don't know well we'll find out
so that's happening what else is
happening how's everybody's weekend
it's good I will you know what I did uh
yesterday with a bunch of my buddies for
my birthday they wanted to hang out when
did the [__] Topgolf thing again dude
Topgolf is everything it's super fun did
you guys have a blast yeah yeah a good
time Topgolf is great I feel like I'm
getting by the end of it I feel it again
you get better at it I did it three
times and by the time I left I was like
okay I'm connecting with this ball yeah
yeah put your balls in my mouth
we had a little surprise you heard me is
my mic working yeah but you're like kind
of I can't hear it hold on usually I can
hear it when it's you got it I was gonna
say we heard a little uh surprise party
for Cameron on Friday that was fun oh
that's true yeah oh we didn't couldn't
talk about it yeah uh I felt weird
because it was actually Dan's birthday
on Friday but my roommate arranged the
party so oh she didn't know she reached
out to me it was like so on Friday the
21st we're doing a surprise party for
cam I'm like
great I'm there so you know though that
is my birthday dude that's that's Stolen
Valor cam it wasn't even your birthday
Dan got birthday cooked I got cucked on
my own birthday it's true but it was fun
I I don't like surprise parties it was
my first time having one um and I felt
very overwhelmed but I appreciate
everyone coming out so thank you that's
nice it's nice to know people care about
you
let me think yeah I tried to justify
that it was a surprise
uh that I was invited to Dan's birthday
party that maybe palleted better that is
a surprise
uh what else
tomorrow is Tuesday I will not be
available to do a see you next Tuesday
the reason is because
Howie Mandel has requested that I return
to his podcast
and I will be doing tomorrow
[Applause]
although do you think how because I'm a
little sick and I know how he's not into
all that
oh I should tell him I should tell him
just I'm a little sick
because I know he's he is uh doesn't
like the German stuff right what are we
doing but I love Howie I want to be
there I want to say hi to his family I
mean his office is amazing he's he
really is a National Treasure I can't
say more I can't say enough nice things
about Howard Howard you know actually
I'm gonna message him right now so I can
find out if we're still on while you're
doing that I just got a big gold Dono
here let's see
uh from Amanda fifty dollars shout out
to my boyfriend Josh it's his 42nd
birthday you're younger than Ethan
came to the live no no no no no no
what's his age uh he's 42 42 okay so
he's four years older than me is that
what you said yeah that's that's what I
said 42. yeah
uh one year younger but check this out
he came to the live show a hater and
left his family wait what interesting
why did you come to the live show as I
hate her no not not that it's her
boyfriend so it sounds like she dragged
him along
that's I mean that's well cheers my dude
to go into a show of people that you
hate
like not that there's not legitimate
reasons to not like me I understand a
lot of people don't but like it's extra
Vibes to go to my live show
well but you well we got you we got him
we got him welcome baby
welcome Josh
I'd throw you a tomato if I saw you I
was uh she said cheers my dude I was at
the mall over the weekend and a fan just
came up to me out of nowhere and just
like held up like a can of something
they're like cheers my dude
big tip
there's uh if you go down to number six
in the Goofs and Gaff section yes people
we have a Goofs and gas oh no way tip
big tip you wish me a happy birthday
because of course that's big tip on
Dan's cake he says oh my God that's
hilarious Happy Birthday dance
team what a vagina looks like
yeah I know bro you're the man dude an
experiences gentle caress I can't lie I
I don't I tipster if you see this I'm
not actually that familiar with your
content I hope you don't take offense to
that I didn't need to say that but I
love all these sound bites they're so
[__] funny like cheers this is my
dude it is catapulted up to uh pretty
much my number one you don't need to be
like yo just so you know I'm not really
a fan what the hell you know I'm not
give some love to our boy big tits I am
giving love he seems like a good guy how
many videos of his have you seen Zach
all the way through oh dude I'm a day
one fan I watch all his streams man
because I've seen zero
but I know who he is because he's just
you know he's big tit you see he's a
legend oops
no he's go dude we love we love tips too
all right so let's let's let's get this
show on the road so the streamies are
back you guys know this happens every
goddamn year
this is it they they announced this year
is different
we're nominated again
and I think this must be our sixth fifth
or sixth time
being the bridesmaid
ever the bride
here's the usual the bride this year you
think so we're gonna put you in a veil
and it's gonna be true it's gonna be
right unlike Leonardo DiCaprio of not
winning Awards except
more talented and handsome Leonardo
DiCaprio
call her Daddy this is your revenant
I feel like we've had a good year yeah
it's been a good one we have absolutely
trashed their Institution
continuously over the past six years
yeah
yeah but it's not about that it's about
who deserves right
well what are we up against here caller
daddy one last year Okay so
back to back unlikely right no yeah no
don't do that right I don't appall
impulsive has also been kind of a
bridesmaid I don't think he's won before
well they let's see what happened to
impulsive this year they uh lost a host
and the main host was accused of
stealing millions of dollars from his
fans right and so they're like let's
nominate them
huge falling out
so I'm kind of had a uh lost for words
at least at least it's not nelk at least
it's not full send true
even the Streamys when stoop that low
and of course my mortal enemy the the
Despicable hateful Jay Shetty it's
disgusting the criminal freak
he makes a killer smoothie let's be
honest oh that smoothie was good so good
smoothies are easy to make good rolls
and raspberry are very complex flavors
25 for a smoothie I could put some
[__] saffron and Truffle in it too
okay I'm ready to try that smoothie
that's what I'm saying let's get the
Ethan Klein smoothie let's taste it and
we can compare it prove to me
that's not a bad idea not a bad idea I'm
gonna outshedy that [__]
and the yard which I guess is a
Ludwig's podcast yep a new Contender who
L what who cares
I'm not gonna say anything bad about
Ludwig I've already I've already [__]
with them enough yeah yeah you you keep
your mouth close I'm still recovering so
I'll do it for you
zero shot
yeah somebody just said Ethan better not
come for the yard it's my number two
point behind H3 uh I didn't and I did
and um thank you for saying that it's
your name I love the yards thank you
thank you
I love the yard
what a fantastic couple they are cutie
Cinderella is such a great great
she really is a great gal and Ludwig
what a multi-talented Legend
she does it all
so I don't know what are you thinking
call her daddy's not going to
doubleheader impulsive if he wins then
it's like why he literally stole like 2
million he did like three scams this
year
on that podcast Jay Shetty I mean give
him a break man he's like dude chill he
doesn't need it I need it the yard if
Ludwig comes in and takes it then
there's going to be a problem
yeah that's there's gonna be hell to pay
so I don't see who else can win this
this year
you know
[Music]
wait what
can't say that
I was I was talking about hypothetical
situations that would happen if I lose
right you hit one of my hypotheticals
went too far it's not going to line up
though because it goes 30 seconds back
yeah I think you were trying to yeah
right but still I I did it oopsie doopsy
about the the Streamys
and and uh listen if you were a uh
executive on that board just know just
use your imagination
okay you give me that award this year
or this is gonna be a problem
[Laughter]
so there it is you want to see what
other nominees do does anyone care uh
let's at least take a look at the big
categories sure well the biggest one
okay I'm just gonna go down to the
biggest one in my opinion then we can
backtrack
but um
hold on the biggest one is this far down
yeah yeah yeah yeah this one's important
hold on
uh sorry I'm almost it must be really
prestigious no I'm almost there it's far
down
a standby
right wait is it no it's not
alphabetical no Jesus okay Jesus brand
of these oh yes of course everybody this
is uh in huge huge competition between
Prime video who I'm rooting for of
course
Amazon hell yes as you know Prime video
is a huge brand and uh yeah I was just
um they're doing incredible things I was
just using it last night is that right I
was
well they deserve brand of the year old
spice who's doing incredible things in
the deodorant world I just used the
school world use them this morning
actually oh me Old Spice me too I'm
right there see I don't use them yeah I
use native yeah I use native oh they
don't need a chance Old Spice tastes
smells like [__] excuse me and I think
it causes Alzheimer's
I'm just kidding that's what they used
to say about the aluminum but I I think
that may have been
uh debunked like the aluminum but maybe
it wasn't too but either way Old Spice
gives you cancer no I'm just kidding I
don't know that
I hope not
just a joke Old Spice don't [__] come
for me I don't know anything
I don't even know what insta360 is
what is that three cameras yeah this
this is a brand of the year
congratulations they've been making big
moves this year big moves well who can
forget Chipotle Mexican Grill brand of
the Year giving people explosive
diarrhea for decades they are on top of
their [__]
we should get some Chipotle today to be
fair I had the same thought I had the
same exact thought do you like Chipotle
love I've never had him oh interesting
here's what I'll say about Chipotle okay
I'll listen 10 years ago
it was like oh crack today I feel like
they've fallen off don't you agree you
guys like it's not as good as I used to
be
but it's still good I've avoided it
because people say they shed themselves
all the time just don't get the spicy
salsa you'll be fine all right cool but
I always get it
I like the spicy sauce it's good weight
loss yeah I don't digest anything I eat
Ian almost died from that [__] dude oh
yeah like gave you like dysentery or
something right what happened yeah I've
I've never gone back like I have not had
it since what happened again
they they gave me some like turbo Bowl
I don't know the origin it just showed
up like a like a cursed artifact in
their store and I ate it they were like
this is this is free they gave it to us
for free so you let you you guys ordered
got all the food plus a mystery Bowl yes
and uh yeah I've never had food
poisoning that that's severe in my
entire life yeah it lasted like weeks
yeah he was like maybe that's the secret
ingredient but I remember at the time
when we pulled the audience how many
people have been sick from Chipotle and
I think it was like 50 nearly 50. I do
remember I do have like quite a few
friends who have been knocked on their
ass dude Chipotle dude if you are given
50 of your customers food poisoning
that's you should be shut down yeah I
think so that being said I think it's
it's got to be the meat because
Chipotle has never made me sick one of
my friends I always got the veggie
burrito know your way around some meat
the sofrita as well yeah I don't I I
just get veggie it's the meat it's got
to be right just sitting around yeah
that being said love it is really good
it's better than Taco Bell I'm looking
at it right now it looks good
I'll get some where's my shirt oh you
got wait you got coronavirus from
Chipotle say I'm saying Nora norovirus
no norov what's norovirus
I I don't know I did she just send that
yes you had like living parasites in
your to put in your book very contagious
virus that causes vomiting and diarrhea
well that was what was happening
yeah not a good time by the way that on
the menu by the way regarding the uh
the aluminum and uh deodorant thing just
so you guys know Alzheimer's drug
discovered Foundation there is no
consistent or compelling evidence to
associate aluminum with
Alzheimer's disease
that was a huge thing because
there's these totally antiperspirant
deodorants they just stop it just plugs
your pores and you don't sweat at all
and it uses some kind of aluminum
compound
and uh people really
got hyped about that being deadly but
it's actually not so there it is give
them a streamy
also uh
all Old Spice deodorants are aluminum
free right so
that's true it's all kind of mood it
doesn't matter also uh we've just looked
it up this is all this is just an
obvious give me to Barbie
who might have the biggest marketing
[__] budget of any movie ever like
every influencer movie star billboard
pre-roll ad it's all Barbie yeah Barbie
marketing budget so they're definitely
gonna win I mean there's no question
about it 150 million on marketing that
sounds like a lot to me but I don't know
if that's a lot for like a triple a
movie
to be honest I mean it's a lot but it's
probably still less than like the Marvel
movies and [__] like like the big one
like Avengers or Spider-Man or whatever
they're getting good bang for their Buck
because I have been so saturated with
Barbie let's see in Avengers marketing
Bobby
this filter is supposed to make you look
like baby
uh 200 million on marketing foreign that
was Avengers end game that's their
biggest movie versus Barbie so it's
pretty close yeah all right but let's
look at these other ones you know what I
mean
yeah
uh go to yeah so let's take a look
creator of the year a rack enemy of the
show said I look ugly in that last year
on dumbass Jay Shetty can you [__] off
why is Jay Shetty here
why is Logan Paul here all he has
literally done is scam people this year
he's just steals people's money
and then says I'll pay you guys back and
doesn't
thanks Streamys any other criminals you
want to promote there
Mr Beast is a criminal why why would you
say that you stole my heart he makes
criminally incredible criminally good
content beast beast has got to win this
I mean if he's I mean no offense to
Gideon he's a good guy I think we
swatched the beef I think but um
Gideon cat win over Mr Beast it's just a
guy who walks around with a camera
versus
um I've crashed a train into a pit
switches it up sometimes recently he
went to a WNBA game and brought a pillow
and blanket and acted like he was
sleeping oh that's not cool
that's not that's not cool bro yeah
those those ladies work hard they don't
need you going there [__] being a
dick for no reason banned indefinitely
from all NBA related events that's just
not funny man see that's what that's my
problem you're just a dick but we squash
the beef you have no chance of winning
but it's nice to be recognized Charlie
demilio again I like her but
what year is this
I don't know you know what I mean I went
when I was looking at this earlier I
went to her Tick Tock to just be like
creator of the Year what's what's she up
to let's see what
what kind of killer content she's doing
you can't really watch any of them
because they all have copyright music I
mean she's still crushing it on the
views she sure is and the content
is it's for young girls Dan it's not for
you it's not even that though it's none
of those things Olivia is it not at
least I listen I I sampled like her 10
most recent videos and what what did you
conclude uh that her content is dog [__]
oh come on
how could you say that I'm sorry that's
crazy it's not entertaining not good but
obviously it's not for me but I don't
understand how it's uh
creator of the Year let's just put it
that way demilio Footwear bro
come on don't be a hater let's get some
demilio Footwear up in this okay I mean
I like those shoes there it is here you
stop now she's creating shoes that's
what's that's the creation is that a
good price it's 130. I mean that's
expensive it's pricey but it's demilio
it's stamelia right which name brand
it's demilio footwork you're paying for
the name let's be real absolutely well
how's your YouTube channel doing maybe
that's part of the equation this is the
first video that's true I only looked at
her Tick Tock so maybe she has him seven
months ago yeah she didn't post her
videos
maybe they were really good and they
just held out for the whole year maybe
on um trailer I sent her trailer yeah oh
thank you let's check her trailer maybe
that has to do with it Sam and I have a
uh demilio mattress
like actually what yeah why did she make
mattresses she did a she did a mattress
collab and Sam picked that one it's
pretty comfortable shout out to Emilio's
man well well here's let me just give
you an idea of how great how popular uh
trailer is Charlie Emilia the most
famous tick tocker maybe ever uh her
last video has thirty thousand plays how
long ago was that 14 000 here
let's see does it show a date July 5th I
didn't think they show a date they hired
it for a reason
they don't say the year they're
embarrassed
I mean to be fair this is unwatchable
what year is it to be fair to the
Thriller audience this is unwashable I
see it cut I see the
see it like creator of the year right
here
no I'm not being mean to Charlie she's
she's a good she's she seems very sweet
he seems very nice it's more what I'm
saying is more a critique of the stream
you said it is hold on I'm listening
okay sorry
it looks like
man
I really can't tell
[Music]
maybe a t-boner why doesn't she post
these winners to Tick-Tock she saves the
good content for trailer right I knew I
had some sort of bone in it
sort of bone in it I don't see these
kinds of videos on her trailer I don't
know why
how much you want to pay that kav paid
her for that [__] too
[__] [__] you probably paid her like
15 million dollars to post that
literally the most incompetent
businessman ever that's Ryan Kavanaugh
my good friend let's see show of the
year or whatever uh
hot ones I don't know most of these why
are we not in show of the Year we're
more a show than a podcast we thought we
gotta address that I kind of agree
because the podcast they don't even read
last year we sent fake Ethan
and
Ian the podcast was announced during a
commercial like they didn't even know it
went down right yeah so why should I go
to your [__] show why should I go to
your event if you don't have any respect
for me or my craft
so true
I do agree though that we do more of a
show
but okay it says podcast in it
stream of the Year Hassan
it's the only option easy dub easy dub
no problem although it's probably gonna
be Kai sanat
he won last year I did
uh if memory serves yeah I believe he
won last year and last year was when he
had his massive blow up so that
definitely made sense
short form like okay
breakout creator yo Keithley right he's
The Tick Tock guy breakout streamer
collaboration
collaboration best collaboration okay
that seems important Mr Beast and The
Rock
when did that happen I don't remember
that I remember I challenged the rock to
rock paper scissors okay all right I'm
Not Gonna Keep hating on every damn
thing whichever one you want wow you
ready this was a big moment though I
don't really think this is a collab this
is like he was doing a press junket
and then ask Rock to play him rock paper
scissors
wouldn't a collab suggests like rock
went to his studio and they made a
project together
yeah yeah probably because like me
running up on a celebrity and like being
like hey play Rock Paper that's not a
collab
not that that's what he did but
yeah I've been stalking um
I've been stalking Jennifer Lopez we've
been collabing for a while now
we we collaborate every night I look
through her window and uh we collaborate
oh no those are jokes please don't
[__] come for me JLo I'm not I don't
I you know I mean I
I don't even know where you live
yeah look probably could find out
he has good security don't worry
no I wouldn't even I wouldn't even dream
of Googling that what am I doing shut up
[__]
anyway here's collab of the year
it is
oh my gosh
[Music]
this is gonna take forever I like rugs
uh I like Rock's outfit as dog boner
he's rock hard dude rock hard dog boner
he looks great man
you ready
okay I'm ready I got it
yes
I didn't know what you meant I looked it
up oh [__] you Google dog boner yeah I
thought it was a character and then I
just saw a big dog have you you've never
had a dog Abe uh I had a little dog a
Pomeranian and then a and then a pug but
I've never seen really never saw the red
when they're puppies that shit's out
like
damn oh yeah I did not come on my door
just a couple of Rich [__] and
that's good though make a wish got 200k
we love that
can I make a wish
that The Rock stops doing [__] movies
where he's in the jungle wearing Safari
[__]
mix it up brother shut up [__] all
right fine
do they have a best YouTube tutorial on
there
because I'd give it to The Nair butthole
dude
I didn't see that category but that's a
shame man he would be a shoe-in wouldn't
he
create a product crunch our feastables
versus Prime Showdown for the ages
uh Prime okay shout out Prime giving
Logan more clout it's good uh feastable
yeah Logan other ones I actually don't
know pop Flex I guarantee you got some
prime
pop Flex
uh workout stuff
close okay it's just a it's a brand is
it it has to be owned by like a YouTuber
or something right I mean yeah it has
less followers than Teddy fresh and less
engagement but uh I don't care oh yeah
it's very fresh no well I was like maybe
this maybe Teddy fresh is different
because like a clothing brand but no pop
Flex is here
interesting no problem
maybe we need to start lobbying like how
people Lobby for the Oscars they put up
uh Billboards around town outside for
your consideration let's find out where
their offices are and just buy a giant
billboard Bays this is luggage which you
know fantastic we love luggage don't we
folks
cool we love luggage
is this related to the internet culture
or streaming I don't know it's a Creator
product so clearly it's owned by oh this
is actually
yeah who owns this it says Below on the
page
oh Shay Michelle it says she Michelle I
don't know who that is that is an actor
and entrepreneur
so she's not an influencer she an actor
or she's a creator
because why don't we just give it to
like [__] Kanye West Yeezy at this
point yeah she appears to be just an
actress in a bunch of movies what are we
doing what does this have to do with the
streamies you robbed Teddy fresh to give
you know uh Kim Kardashian skins Creator
product of the year right
Kim Kardashian no respect Mark Roper I
know good guy let's see
what is crunch Labs uh oh it's like for
kids okay I like these stuff this is
cool oh that's pretty cool yeah that
actually does look cool Vsauce I don't
know if Vsauce kind of did this first
he had like a box of curiosity boxes
yeah yeah I guess it's a similar kind of
thing
but okay go get it I'm I'm rooting for
him because you know
well that's I don't even think these
other people are creators well Mr B Mr
Beast yeah
okay oh [__] we got our sign up saline
ultra fine nasal mist to be honest the
more I talk the more my throat hurts so
I said who wants a bottle of DayQuil but
Dan was the only taker
I didn't get my own bottle are you there
no she got me a uh cynex saline ultra
fine nasal mist is that what you asked
for no
um can I watch you apply it I've never
done this before so I'm gonna read the
instructions I've used them on my on my
kids they work really good huh
feels like a [__] massive there's
some nitrous yeah it looks like I'm
gonna be huffing uh it's just like a
Mist it's just like a watery Mist okay
um that looks dangerous so Dan show Dan
look into the camera
so I just stick it in there and spray
this and breathe it seems kind of no no
no yeah no it's breathe it and be like
right you want to put it up there real
deep stick your finger
yeah yeah
okay here we go
wait what happened oh you did it yeah I
did it you did a heart your finger was
shaking you're pushing hard
it helps yeah you're gonna feel better
you gotta do that
sniffing it sniffing it I'm waiting for
the chat to be like why the [__] did you
do it like that that's the wrong way
supposed to go in your ear dude what are
you doing no dude if you if you
there's a risk of stroke if you do it
like that a bowl or go to the sink LOL
in all caps okay do you not want to
watch this because it doesn't make sense
they're catching up and I'm seeing a lot
of no-nos and LOLs so I don't know just
do it Dan all right I'm going I'm going
around
it's starting to rain no no no Danny you
need to what happened
it brought you to tears wait what
happened I don't know it feels pretty
good though so okay but now read the
directions now that you've done that I
did read the directions now that you've
spritzed to your brain
let's see I mean it just says it's
purified water and I do those too sodium
chloride you've got to angle it in to
your brain like it's you're into the
brain hey your nose doesn't go straight
up it goes inward all right why the [__]
did you do it like that no stop it's not
it's me it says put it in your nose is
it you're acting like that's crazy guys
guys dance fine please we have a limited
time today it was fine thank you thank
you uh the Mystic Stoner okay Stoner
knows what they're talking all right
listen cheers my dude cheers my dude
love ya no homo hmm
yummy
[__]
unwashed [__] flavor
all right what do we got here let's move
on we actually have stuff to talk about
Bryce and fousey have made peace
which is exciting that's fousey on his
stream and also guess what Brad the bull
was there
that's right
who's [__] Kavanaugh's EX
check it out yeah look oh look can I
kiss you on the cheek yes I will give
you
thank you look see I asked for consent
now before putting my hands on people I
asked for consent
right
honestly I like the way fousey
talked about it me too Brad are you not
embarrassed to be cruising with the 20th
year old like I mean Brad thanks for
taking care of her brother couldn't you
be at home [__] Ryan's wife
how do you even time to do any of this
[__]
now Brad's cool though Brad's cool I uh
he's actually a friend of the show I've
connected with him
connected with him yeah I talked to him
on the phone you guys did touch base
once
I like to touch tips
he's very handsome jacked he's like he
looks just like [__] Moses he's like
Moses but swole yeah I I don't I can't
deny it the resemblance is crazy and
they're both Israeli I think too
um
that's what it is guys I don't know what
to tell you
that's good
gotta make sure people heard that I just
blew so much snot out of my nose just
now
yeah
we have more foosi updates Big Friend of
the show energy here
[Applause]
is Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein that's a good question you
don't know them that's a good question
from the audience
thank you for the reset for 13 months
win let me show you a picture
oh yeah which one the left
watch and I love how fousey doesn't let
it go he has to make sure everybody sees
it and gives their opinion which is
everything to me welcome the Channel
showing on here but it's showing on
screen Ryan what do you mean
Jasmine dare you to jump in the pool
look do these two people look alike no
you don't have to jump in the pool guys
pay attention
look pay attention yes yes
yeah he lost one lost weight the person
just lost weight thank you so there it
is that's three random yeah swimmers
I don't know who they are yeah so shout
out fousey big friend of the family
Vibes the top of them is he's so H3
build
that's so true did he understand that
that was no he figured it out because
people have been gotcha telling him
about it you've been watching a b yeah
I've been I've been he been hyping oh
yeah yeah no he's all in his act show
he's he's holy [__] that's awesome wait
he's going to your show Zach I just
found this I just told him I didn't I
have no idea about that you can guest
list him right
[Laughter]
yeah yeah well uh I'll uh I'll figure
something out genuinely I'm not saying
this to to be silly it would be good for
you to have no no no I'll uh yeah I'll
have them on there
because then he'll film it there'll be
Clips on the subreddit people will be
his audience will watch everyone's gonna
say damn Zach Lewis sounds good yeah I'm
gonna see him at the next show Zach
Lewis experience I'll add him to that
very tight tight guess exclusive baby
uh what is this here
um
Lucy shits himself in Airbnb and leaves
it for maintenance to clean oh that's
not good
so sorry what he [__] himself I guess he
sharted on stream he didn't show it he
didn't show anything so he's good but um
he was like late for his flight and had
to go and
I guess this is the the review that
Airbnb left
oh no way yeah okay so let me read this
now I got it in there Adam was a
self-sufficient guest and commutative up
until the check-in process unfortunately
more guests were on site than disclosed
in the original booking and the home was
left dirtier than the average guest upon
checkout that's not okay you know one of
the guests in the party seemingly soiled
themselves in the bed
this caused feces and other substances
to be stained on sheets to face and the
bathroom before
what is happening the guest also left
heavily soiled underwear on the property
for the maintenance team to find that
sounds like a nightmare I pooped my
pants okay well if he's not drinking
which he's not he's sober this man just
he had he couldn't control his [__] he
was in bed he started shooting he ran to
the bathroom [__] everywhere
left his shitty underwear on the floor
wait but I'm so that didn't clean so is
that his real name or something no what
is it a last name yeah what is it Nadeem
is probably his friend who was renting
it oh so it's on the team fousey's
venison yeah so how do we know and and
fousey posted this he posted this under
the the clip of him charting Oh I
thought that day he's made good
yeah he had tacos he said they had tacos
okay good he's a good man I know he
would make it right he wouldn't you know
what I mean no I'm saying the tacos
cause the the the the [__] oh yeah [__]
so it was fousey
and is he doing anything for this poor
guy I'm poor guy this guy owns a [__]
Airbnb he can handle it come on he's got
to clean [__] out the [__] bed yeah
welcome to running a hotel dude really
is that the expectation
actually it's done in La it says to
Nashville Tennessee I was in Tennessee
um we out here in Tennessee don't kindly
to [__] in the bed
I don't know what yeah
small town he was trying to clean I
believe he he did miss his flight he did
end up missing it oh he made an effort
okay he missed his flight for you
Brandon what more do you want
yeah we love him for that
uh there's more so many fousey stuff
um
secret question is he should he tell a b
he [__] his pants what what was that
because you were gonna make your car
dirty what was the contest I wasn't I
didn't know you [__] his pants and then
I I picked him up when Lena's car and uh
I guess he didn't have time to do a
complete shower so he was had shitty
pants bro but he was on the bath he was
on the plane with shitty pants
five hour flight the best stream in the
[__] world yo his neighbor must have
been tripping
Lucy you gotta wash your [__] brother
he said he cleaned but uh I don't think
he had time for a full shower did you
smell anything
when I put the top up oh my god there
was a spell
yeah a little bit oh my God
let me I have a thing here oh no if you
[__] yourself
you have time for a shower you make time
it doesn't matter what you're doing what
you have planned you have time for a
challenge high priority oh he's watching
live apparently should we pull it up
let me pull up [__] stream
yeah you know what I mean like you could
what you could clean your ass in like 30
seconds bro
oops not that
Boosie on Twitter you just commented in
the chat he said I changed my underwear
he changed his underwear that's not
enough bro that's not it helps to help
this [__] is on the ass like it's good
that you cheat I mean that'd be crazy
not to change your underwear man but you
got a wipe your you got to clean your
ass dude oh here he is
when I put the top up hey you didn't
tell me it smelled
it's funny because he's the one who said
it he said once the window I don't I had
a flight at 6am
of course you smell it you had a shitty
[__] if I could defend my boy the guy
is an Entertainer is doing 24 7.
sometimes you just gotta show must go
sometime
I get it wow
no you can't Ethan you can't
see on Twitter
what how is that enough you got [__] in
your ass why are we pretending that you
don't shower after you poop yourself
why are we all babies
you cleaned your [__] he did clean it
he told me
my flight was at 6 00 am it was like 5
a.m when I woke up I didn't have time to
shower I changed my underwear and I wet
the toilet paper and I cleaned it good
wet the toilet paper I mean it sounds
like he made an effort give me an effort
he didn't just just roll with it I don't
know man I think you got it at a certain
point you just gotta be like I'm missing
that flight you know what I mean
yeah I don't know I don't know
worthless what did you [__] the bed
[__] 6am was was were you the one were
you the one that [__] in the hotel bed
yeah I mean he must have right well I
didn't know it was under someone else's
name yeah it was him but he I mean he
like I said
subscribe to this video
[Laughter]
yeah yeah towel
and I went it so serious well this is
serious accusation right I would want to
equip myself of these charges as well
yeah I will say it was only when he said
something that I I I it kind of hit me
but it was only for a second there's
synaptic fatigue so I didn't I didn't
smell the whole time I'm sick
I guess
towel so the phone doesn't overheat
all right [__] you be good all right we
love you be well next time just use a
baby wipe or some soap or something you
know what I mean
what do you say was I was the one that
was
it's just so compelling I could watch
this all day frankly
you know yay
all right Phil see you take care
we love you welcome to the fam
all right
it's exciting
very exciting
hey uh we haven't talked about keemstar
in a while
he actually um
I gotta say this is more of an inspiring
piece I I haven't talked about him a
while and I think my my distaste for him
is maybe dissipated and I'm at the point
where I can pay him a compliment Daddy
he actually had a really touching
um student daughter dance at the prom
not student daughter like father
daughter
yes I meant father daughter yeah yeah he
took his daughter to like prom and they
choreographed the whole dancing oh
that's actually pretty wholesome and I
was like okay maybe he is a good dad
nice
wait that's oh [__] no that's his
girlfriend no Brantley no no no that's
his daughter right
[Music]
well why would he be grabbing his
daughter's ass well it's just part of
the dance move what's your argument
oh did she just say couples talking
balls
okay so it may be his daughter or his or
his girlfriend it's hard to tell huh but
it well he does kind of grow that's not
inappropriate for a daughter
that's your argument
that wouldn't be an appropriate touching
spot
yeah it could heal a moment like kind of
like didn't intend to like grab their
okay
is this a romantic move here for a
daughter father daughter dance this
whole like dip or can the father
daughter do a dip
they could do it platonic dips exist
yeah platonic dips okay okay yeah I'll
dip you anytime
yeah okay you dip me like that that's
nice get me like keemstar dips Brantley
[Music]
uh that's really inspiring so it's as a
as a as a new father myself it's nice to
see good Dads out there yeah having an
impact on their kids lives
I will say they are both great dancers
seriously you can tell that you see the
way they move yeah it's passion yeah
yeah it's fashion across the floor you
know it's fatherly love
[Music]
all right yo bro I'm at this high school
girl that I was hot as [__] tonight
are you sure you want to say that sounds
like like uh acoustic version or some
[__] like it doesn't make sense keemstar
do you want to take back that comment
about hot high school girls because that
is a little off a 10 year old fan right
away
foreign
okay that's even worse that's really
[__] up
what the [__] oh brother speaking okay
we'll move on Jim uh okay this is this
is pretty good
look like Jimmy Lee
hold on [__] why does he look like Jimmy
they look so similar
I really that hairline is everything
hold it
you gotta really take it in
chocolate mocha you know colored cream
yeah they're all different flavors
he's scary
his face is scary
it looks like Ollie London also a little
bit you know what I mean
I see a mixture
the Shadows or something it's just
Sinister and the clown eyewear what is
it is that serious eyewear is that like
designer or is that like I imagine I
mean
how how many joking outfits does James
Charles wear you know
yeah and seem like his style it's pretty
wild
there he looks like Jimmy Lee so I mean
a compliment to Jimmy
oh who does try to insist that he's like
30 so Hello Olivia
yeah he is
here maybe this is what's happening
I love that even that's the red glasses
even in Jamie's puff like Photoshop
piece the hairline
is so visible I'm sorry babe
I gotta say man
yeah Jimmy's looking good by comparison
Chad said that
it looks like a prolet his sunglasses
looks like a pro his eyes are prolapsing
a little bit yeah uh this was a nice
exchange I I enjoyed on Twitter young
gravy friend of the show
dream
so is everybody over dream let's go
Minecraft cheater
he showed his face he took the face back
and he makes he's no longer he asked us
to uh to forget what he looks like right
yeah we're not we're not really trying
to neuralize us I'm allowed to remember
what he looks like now
he looks like Dollar Store Shane Dawson
you know okay whatever why don't you be
mean to dream but anyway he is trying to
make music which is like you know
Creator music whatever so he says hey
young gravy let's
do a collab and young gravy just said
nah
which is nice no
he didn't even have to respond he did
you know what I mean yeah no he went out
of his way
with it make sure that it was a no hey
bad Barbie I hope you like this drawing
I'll give you I do not but I [__] with
you for trying that's one of my
favorites of all time
Fair
I do not but and then dream continues to
pathetically beg him in the comments but
please he responded
like bro take the L on this one man
just got gravied
yeah people so many of the chat's
reminding us that the dream basically
was doing similar [__] to James Charles
okay so I've tried to look into that and
I'm iffy I'm not just super familiar but
I'd love to learn more I know that
people have caught made those
accusations against them I don't know if
it's harder to figure out or something
but I haven't found
as compelling of a compilation I don't
even want to say yeah I don't even want
to say that because I listen I'm not
trying to downplay anything that's out
there I just don't know gotcha well more
importantly he cheated at Minecraft well
yeah that's a big deal yeah and then
and pretend that like it was an accident
but it definitely
what is dream up to anyway let's be real
let's check his channel
have you heard this in post have you
heard his music no
would you like to I don't know are we
gonna get claimed oh maybe
I absolutely would love to hear it oh my
God yes yeah test it see if it's clean
it's going this guy these all these guys
think they're like World Superstar
typical Mr worldwide's in the making
[Music]
looking like a moon yeah everybody said
that he looked like a moon in his uh
face reveal thing
what does that mean uh specifically uh
what's the the moon from the old
McDonald's commercials Mac Tonight Mac
tonight okay wait I got to see that yeah
uh so here's Mac tonight for those of
you that were born after uh 1988.
okay
map tonight
yeah creepy ass
looking [__] right there
and then
until he's got like a long pointy kind
of face
yeah dream face reveal
yeah you see how it's kind of Crescent
yeah yeah yeah and it has a crescent
moon I don't think that's necessarily an
insult though to say your Moon I mean
you could say a lot worse things than
that you have a well-sculpted face
that's what it says to me people just
call me straight up ugly bro
okay whatever all right dream
gravy says no that's gonna be a pass dog
and uh let's see some other uh Recaps
from the weekend the R Place War
took on a lot of shapes thank you to
everybody who was participating here's
the best one that came out of it
Dan made an appearance were you involved
in this love
no not at all I think it's led by this
is crazy Papa lynnae I think is the
leader of wow yeah so that's pretty good
shout out yeah yeah I woke up to like a
bunch of people having sent this to me
and even like friends that don't know
that don't watch the show and we're like
what the [__] dude they just randomly
saw your face yeah yeah they just
stumbled upon it
here's the H3 logo the Dan one is is
really good is it still there
I don't know is it still going the place
thing yeah yeah it's still up
um here I'm checking if is there another
ago and then well this actually was
probably the best yeah still here look
at that hold up
how big is it hold on I'm gonna see how
big is it oh Jesus pretty small that's
not bad no that doesn't mean I mean it's
decent could be smaller it could
definitely be smaller I mean Taylor
Swift reputation era is smaller than Dan
that's all switched that's pretty
incredible is that oh is that that's T
Swift on the top right and t-swift on
the top uh on the bottom right so it's
me and then two Taylor Swift yeah album
covers so are you are we alive with the
swifties
uh evidence must be right love Yeah
there must be some sort of uh at least
truce going on here that's awesome dude
I love the swifties wow
yeah but this one actually was uh pretty
fantastic does Ryan Kavanaugh look like
Harvey weinstein.com
now that that's awesome is good and if
you guys are curious what the [__] is
this that looks like crazy
I just saw this recommended on you know
a lot of people were doing these uh
Cosmo outfits for in this whole meme
Abby here's the guy just to give him
some love
this is Papa lynnae
good work Soldier
's in the house well done
awesome
um
all right let's get into some God yeah
this is yeah I don't know what he means
I mean he looks just like his mask
anyway
laughs
that is
nightmare fuel all right so we got
Twitter
changing excuse me
Twitter changing their name to X
FaZe rug sour challenge we should do
that oh yes so dude I was watching I was
on tick tock
a random poker video came up
or was it on YouTube I don't remember
but I randomly came across a video about
cheating and poker
and they're like these guys got
permanently banned for a collusion and
cheating
and then I was like is that soflo
Antonio
was caught cheating at a [__] poker
table
it's [__] awesome can you believe
that yes
less than 24 hours after appearing on
Hustler Casino Live
so apparently this guy Julio was his
friend mm-hmm
and they were colluding together this
comes after allegations that uh
he was looking over and seeing his
opponent's card making unusual plays
afterwards well okay if you're
obviously it's pretty corny to look over
at your partner's card but you should be
protecting that [__] opponent's card
yeah yeah that I mean if you're flashing
your cards that's the dumbest way to uh
cheat
nobody's going to notice this
they're so obvious it's insane like I'm
cheap throughout the whole match or I
don't know what you call it the whole
game they keep looking over well a lot
of people have said a lot about sofa
Antonio and um one of those things that
has not been said about him is that he's
smart
everything else has been said about him
and yes Dreams Music look at a house a
Dilo shows his hand here by his body
language and the way he tables his cards
is like someone who has quads and was
100 confident that he had the best hand
this was the second red flag the next
hand he does the exact same thing trying
to peek at his whole cards and this time
he does not love the river knowing Barry
paired his Queen oh honestly kind of
surprised
the next hand was the most controversial
one which made even the commentators
question what was going on I was like
holy [__] that's so flow Antonio he's
sitting there playing poker with like
money he scams from Facebook SARS masks
and he's cheating at that
a former YouTube prankster who is
apparently cedillo's friend the hand
began with Antonio
he's for off suit on the button skills
rocks holding 9-7 suited called from the
small blind and then Barry made the call
from the big blind with 10-8 off suit
flop comes out a79 which is an action
flop the blinds checked to Antonio who
bets out thousand and both Players
called the turn comes as six of Spades
making barrier straight again the action
checks to Antonio and here's where it
gets weird sadillo apparently kicks
Antonio under the table to slick slick
operators huh
yeah so obviously colluding is when two
players um
work together pass information to each
other which is cheating for me cheating
and um these are the dumbest people on
Earth this man is straight up peaking at
cards like this and then kicking homie
and they're so dumb he goes are you
kicking me right now
okay message received buddy got it well
blind and then Barry made the call from
the big blind with 10-8 off suit flop
comes out a79
blind check to Antonio who bets out
thousand and both everybody's played
Checkers but soflo's cheating at poker
thank you
it's called the turn comes a six of
Spades making barriers straight again
the action checks to Antonio and here's
where it gets weird sadillo apparently
kicks Antonio
doesn't get the hint and appears and
then he's too dumb to get the hint
cedillo here has two pair he gives it
some Hollywood and then Falls that's an
unusual play in this spot for a loose
player unless yeah makes no sense he has
he has a two pair
there's literally no way yes of course
you happen to know the player track
behind you has the absolute nuts he said
you kicking him and then you're gonna
fall bro if he folds he's not folding
this is an angle oh really 100
it's unclear whether cedilla was trying
to get the other player Antonio to fold
or possibly cedilla was trying to get
Antonio to check the turn so he who had
flapped two pair could see a free River
and try to fill up and stag Barry who
had the straight Barry eventually wins a
19 500 part from Antonio but he noticed
something was fishy between cedillo and
Antonio and gets up from the table to
take a breather yeah I'll be talking
about
[Music]
that's the biggest scumbag in YouTube
history and it just randomly out there
it's wild how I feel like every year or
two
he pops up again like and it's always
with like some new [__] scheme he's
like Kaiser so say but like totally
incompetent
he's like the worst Kaiser so say he's
Kaiser so so
no not that one the roar roaring roaring
there it is that was a good one Kaiser
there it is
they love me
all right all right
um Corral oh the Crowder story is pretty
great too
uh and we didn't get to that last week
oh God the new law firm this guy makes p
and p look like uh Mother Teresa let's
go this guy he must have seen his
tick tock
okay and then there's this new guy
jayoma Law Firm
okay and this is the actually I we had
reviewed one of his videos before long
time ago but he didn't have a lot of
content
and I'm happy to say that since then
this video is it David's never gone done
anything like this I mean this is stuff
this is worse than anything David's done
well you tell me these videos are crazy
this is what I saw on my feed
okay okay the first one I saw just like
a few days ago you tell me what the [__]
you think about this all right
all right G uh what are you charged with
uh and decency of a child what sexual
contact all right and how much prison
time are you looking at uh 20 years and
uh were you facing to be put on a sex
offender registry list yes I was and uh
what did they accuse you of doing
um touching the breast of a
child and the vagina of a child okay and
uh what okay the fact that he's making
him say that is stunning on its own what
this is Way Beyond anything I've ever
seen on PMP
I think David would be like that's
[__] up dude yeah
I mean [__] man you know I have a child
okay and um so you're probably wondering
where I called you right yeah
so this guy's even less professional he
hasn't even told him what happened he
called him drove to him made him say all
that crazy [__] and then he goes now let
me show you what the judge says he
doesn't know yet
that's got to be that has to be
an Ethics violation this doesn't seem
ethical man
yes
[Music]
all right so what does that say uh
dismiss all right so I got your case
dismissed wow that's crazy man all right
so you don't have not happy enough
wow that's we just got out of 20 years
of going into prison as a child predator
that's pretty sick like what is
happening thanks bro
at all at all right and you avoid the 20
years prison time yeah all right are you
happy yeah most definitely all right
um one of the greatest lawyers in
Houston that I know of most definitely
um yeah so I did some [__] up [__]
waited a while for this and um yeah I'd
refer him out to anybody
oh then he even includes the goddamn
[__]
State's motion to dismiss
you're doing too much bro style number
so here's the there's so many layers to
this because it's like
we don't know anything about
this particular case no maybe this guy
was falsely accused right sure and it's
actually a good thing that it got
dismissed or it was inevitable that I
was going to get dismissed because it
was all trumped up or whatever but now
he's on vid like that guy will forever
be a sex offender without being charged
of being a sex offender because he did
that video bro that was with David's
videos because it's like you're putting
them on blast this is actually yeah he
if if he's innocent right all you got to
do is show someone this video and
they'll be like ah maybe not let's not
run the risk
I mean he didn't he didn't try to
clarify it in the video to be fair he
was just like these are my charges
his reaction was very odd I agree do you
think I was innocent thank you the top
government he did that church for sure
Pro it's all good man
he regretted agreeing to this
oh man I don't think he did yeah why
would you want this posted he says Ah
this is not the one bro
usually these videos are funny when it's
about speeding or something but this is
just sick
oh man I'm not gonna read it
I was blown away by that yeah but
there's more
um there's more and my favorite genre of
his videos is he'll go into the prison
and interview them through the plastic
that's authentic that that because part
of me was like is this guy real is this
all just like a joke but then you go to
his page and you're like oh no no no
this this is real look at this all right
oh who's the best lawyer oh my God oh my
God
here's your best lawyer bro what are you
charged with
um accurate a son a family member I mean
he's in jail so you kind of [__] up
already
all right and how much personal time are
we looking at like 30 years
all right so you're getting out today
right
yeah oh good man appreciate it man yeah
how fast did I get that [__] dismissed
man
get that [__]
I can't even hear him
it's just like
and I love how he posts the receipts
David doesn't do that
oh that's a professional so here is a
here's a great one from uh Jo
Mala
j j o j Oma J Oma law yeah ayoma law
all right
it looks like they're an interrogation
room so this one's gonna be good where's
the best movie and why am I the best say
my name
say my name baby
you smart this is crazy
got my case dismissed and uh what are
you charged with I sat on a pregnant
person and uh how much person tell me
not a big deal
I punched my pregnant girlfriend in the
stomach a stult of a pregnant person
Jesus Christ
Ten Years bro uh what did they accuse
you of doing punching and slapping my
baby mama okay and um are you happy with
the results hell [__] yeah all right
and is there anything else you want to
add
man hire this man bro did that hardest
man
dude he's getting awful domestic abusers
for child Predators I mean this guy's
got swag
and he put his face out there on that
horrible Vibes oh here is horrible Vibes
coming off these videos actually here is
uh him with his new client Jared Fogle
he's working on getting him out
yeah it turns out the calls were
fabricated those calls were not real
yeah
uh here's another one
um
oh God
these are so crazy who's the best lawyer
you are say my name is he really
humiliated them and these are like seem
like hard in kind of Street Savvy people
like who wouldn't want to be humiliated
but
they got it dude because he's Joma
he's like kingpin You Gotta you gotta
kiss the ring
all right B who is the best lawyer you
are and uh why am I the best lawyer
because you got my case dismissed and uh
what were you charged with aggravated
assault with the Twitter family member
the deadly weapon ah you forgot deadly
weapon
dayoma remembers
how much uh prison time are you looking
at 99 years and are you happy with the
results yes I am 99. you're the best
thank you
I tried to kill my family member
you're the best thank you I was facing a
hundred years of prison
Jesus
we gotta get like a picnic together with
all of his acquitted clients 100 just
see what happens the potluck
mm-hmm
somebody's gonna get killed there for
sure
here's a girl who is a uh here's another
one really violent people
and why am I the best lawyer because
again my case dismissed yeah what are
you charged with terroristic threat
terroristic threats it gets crazier
are you like a little scared that she
did that Jay
no people in the comments kept talking
about how she's like opening her eyes
every so often like oh for real pretty
big like I did that [__]
she's just plotting her next one
oh yeah okay she's like yeah this [__]
was crazy
and um are you happy with the results
yes you got my case dismissed oh [__]
I'm so happy oh my God
none well how much were you looking at a
year in jail okay oh just one year for a
terrorist technology
I love this guy
with it with it okay good for him man
you know if Timothy McVeigh had jaoma
maybe he would have gotten off would
have been a whole different game just
saying man
um
here's one more dude where
all right oh God
this is our boy Jay Oma you guys this is
gonna make you appreciate uh PNP
all right d who is the best lawyer and
why am I the best because he made my
case go away and uh what were you
charged with I got a very sexual assault
for under a kid all right he's like
don't forget the kid
aggravated sexual assault against a kid
okay stop it I can't do this
bro Dave all right I'll wrap it up let's
let's say even if the guy is innocent
there is no need to put this online
you're talking about
the assault of a four-year-old child
let's not
let's not smile at the camera and do
this whole thing man
that's psycho dude there's a
four-year-old out there who is a victim
and we're posting on Texas
because he got our case dismissed
did you do any type of jail time no no I
didn't and uh are you happy with the
results yeah yes I am and is there
anything else you want to add oh he's
the best lawyer because he fights for
what's right and he knows every single
step that he takes is gonna lead to
somewhere else where he gets to be a
better lawyer and knows his right step
to be like to fight for what's right for
your safe right totally yeah right for
your sake like what's right for you good
fight for what's right he knows all the
loopholes oh I know the comments are
going to be good on this one
hold on
let's see let's go he did it for sure
that's the funny thing like even if he's
innocent right now everybody in the
comments is like he did that it's just
on every level this is just not I like
you Jama but you should have kept this
one to yourself
ain't no way bro agreed for you to post
this
oh my God you should have kept this one
in the vault
what is wrong with this guy how did this
guy pass the bar he like like dude what
who is this guy
he seems like he knows his [__] it's
Joma dude that's Joma
I'd love to hear a combo between him and
David
right just a totally uncensored P J Oma
Law Firm if you could catch them a hot
mic like talking uncensored about their
practice I'm pretty sure they'd both end
up in jail
disarmed this farted in prison yeah
let me do one more um jailhouse
these are my faves
this one looks interesting it's so it's
like boomy like you can't hear [__] I
don't blame him
this one all right a who's the best
lawyer and why am I the best lawyer
[Music]
how much jail time are you looking on
them
all right and are you happy with the
results satisfied
all right is there anything holy [__]
you're facing 99 years for robbery no
you know what he's facing for trying to
kill
um Krusty the Clown
foreign
God
that is such a good connection that you
just made holy [__]
he got the results I wanted
um
good audio this man is
the right one to give him a car any type
of problem he gonna get you right he
gonna get it done all right and you're
getting out of jail today right yes sir
all right sounds good how long you been
in jail man I've been here six and a
half
brother I'll see you out when you get
out all right
he's just gonna try to kill Krusty again
you guys know how it goes it was Bart oh
bar no at first it was crusty and then
and Barb foiled him and then Barton came
his arch nemesis right I guess I need to
brush up on myself since Lord dude
that's embarrassing
hey you know what I just had an idea
why don't I take the call
mute the mic
because I don't think it'll be longer
than like five minutes
and then I can tell everybody
what happened on the call
do we love that idea or do we hate it
that is so sick
there's a risk of Michael longer yeah
yeah I know the people want it the
People Want it they they the more
intimate the better they want to see my
[__] they want to see my medical
records and I'll show it to them no
problem that's why I'm that's why I'm so
successful I'll show them my medical
records
I'll even but you know what let's not
mute the mic
let's not do
this no no you can't do that to the
doctor I'm kidding that's a joke that's
a joke
I wouldn't do that a big doctor I'm live
to 50 000 people can I uh stream this
call
you'd be like no
no absolutely not are you crazy
you need to up your game people are
[__] their pants on stream you know
yeah yeah I heard that that's wrong I
mean if I [__] my pants I show it to you
but
haven't shipped myself in a while you'd
show it to us I get I mean if they want
to see it I don't know I did show them
my pesto [__] right I guess that's true
I guess that seal has already been
broken all right let's do the sour
do you guys want to order Chipotle is
that a thing yeah
I'm cool on that one brother you're
skipping I'll sit down is it just like
do you have a problem with Chipotle are
you dieting or what no no the bowl is
actually a perfect meal for me with no
rice just I I won't uh
you won't I'll feel bad for you guys
just put it that way
oh cause it's gonna make you fart fart
well no I'm gonna kill the toilet dude
oh yeah really it does it just goes
right through you like that dude
wow Next Level and Ian would you order
it would you eat it if I ordered are you
still out
no I I still like living yeah I think
he's like forever I'm not over it yet
that's like Sharkies
now we're talking you know about
Sharkies
are just an item to you love
Charlie they have a Mexican pizza at
Sharky's which is actually insanely good
it's good like if you like that Taco
Bell do you like the Taco Bell Mexican
pizza I never tried it
it's so [__] good
we can do Sharkies yeah from Sharky's is
interesting interesting
um
okay well let's do the sour stuff
we'll do the Sharky stuff I'll do the
Sharky stuff I don't know if there's a
shark why am I the best lawyer deliver
here
unbelievable you do God's work you you
yeah I don't know anybody that's messing
with you you push the hardest you're
consistent you're always pushing you're
pushing you're pushing you don't you
don't and
you
know I'm gonna lost some words right now
I don't even know what to say so how
many charges do you have I have five
charges and were they involving a deadly
weapon all deadly weapons all aggravated
all deadly weapons all day baby you know
how it is you know we keep it all day
and it's just unbelievable right here yo
boy put in the Tipping justice of scales
GIF in there pretty high tech
see that
is it balanced
you got you got you got all four you got
all my other bonds reinstated and then
where I've been and what I've been
through and the cases that I got all
right ain't no way all right this is the
man right here sounds good this is a
billionaire lawyer right here all right
let's see him on the news then sounds
good
definitely gonna be killed by one of his
clients we'll see him on the news later
all right
I'll see you when you get up yes sir
most definitely all right do you have
anything else you want to say to the
people out there man just man just stand
lock your doors people
lock your doors and I I'll tell you I'm
armed and I'm free
[__] your doors
thank you best lawyer oh God
oh for some reason me watching H3 sends
my dad into a rage about how dumb and
useless the show is
do you want your dad to call in I'll
talk to your dad that was I was gonna
say reach up I want to talk to this
person's dad
thank you
I gotta know that Dad
I'll turn him into a fan oh meet that
Dad all right you guys ready for the
sour stuff who wants to go first yeah I
guess well so hold on there's a little
bit of uh setup involved yeah because
when you open the box there's a
neutralizer agent that you need to make
so let me grab let's get some cups with
some water this is pretty interesting I
have never seen anything like it yeah
there's a neutralizer which I guess
it's kind of feels as a powder
and is everybody down to do this one
okay that's fine yeah I mean it's not
it's not gonna ruin your life like the
damn yeah no it's spicy as long as I'm
not in like
pain for more than five seconds I'm cool
so let's see it says mix the neutralizer
and water to prepare it you put three
gummies in your mouth suck for 30
seconds without making a face
then you could spit out chew or swallow
the gummies it's up to you
you decide
so
to clean mouth and teeth swish
neutralize your mouth for 10 seconds
then spit or swallow
what does this have to do with Cash Out
download cash app and get your cash tag
for a chance to win prizes oh we're
doing the David dobrik thing yeah
just sell the product bro you know you
don't have to do the goddamn
David dobrik [__]
I'm kind of excited for this
it says not recommended for people with
history of uh soft enamel soft teeth
sensitive mouth tissue or people with
reflux heartburn uh oh
that's me in fact I couldn't even sleep
last night my
reflux was so bad I have to like elevate
my head keep the acid from going in my
[__] throat and because I have a sore
throat it makes it so much worse dude I
go through periods without do I gotta
sit up and sleep sometimes it's so bad
you should medicate it I take it when it
kind of flares up
almost but that's not how it works you
have to take it regularly
it helps for me I don't think it even
works until like a couple days
yeah I think it does I think it does I
talked to a doctor maybe it helps you
yeah all right so do we do two packs of
neutralizer
I think you're supposed to have two
glasses all right we also have the video
of phase of Mr rug uh
we're gonna phase up before we go
I think we should
seems only right all right well no
um oh I see that who wants to take the
Sharky's order uh I looked it up there
or
we're in a Sharky's desert oh no no yes
[__] there are no Sharkies anywhere near
where we are so uh oh look at that
background so cool
the sour seed
probably already went through all this
but uh I'm just seeing it all right
I got my neutralizer here let me pull up
rugs video I guess
here's rug
the sour Legend So here's how the sour
gummy challenge works you have your box
and when you open it this is what you're
gonna see the actual sour gummies and
two packets of neutralizer so the goal
of this challenge is to withstand the
intensity of these sour gummies for 30
seconds without making a face or
spitting the gummies out first things
first you start with your neutralizer
packets
I tasted the neutralizer taste that [__]
the water
does it taste good that's the real
challenge why would I put that in my
mouth it tastes like a like fun dip
stick yeah wait so then I'm excited to
take a sip try it wait there's no
[__] way I like that yeah you crazy
bro tears my dude I'd slam this all day
cheers that's yummy what
it's nice and sweet and it's vile it
tastes like I'm drinking syrup it's
delicious I actually like it quite a I
would drink drink this in front of like
Coke that's crazy that's crazy holy [__]
man I recoiled I don't know what it was
it's pure sugar
all right uh go ahead uh go ahead uh rug
shake it up boom so now that you have
the neutralizer you set it aside it's
time for the actual challenge so in this
packet there are six gummies you
actually only need three for this
challenge we got the three gummies here
there's three gummies left in here in
case you fail The Challenge and want to
try it again or you could challenge your
friends you can't make a gummy bear so
generous of him to include six to be
honest yes uh pretty cool for that one
dose yeah oh sure
a little shiny and wet that's probably
what you'll notice when you open the
pouch so now it's time for the fun part
the challenge is you pop these three
gummies into your mouth and you try to
suck on them for 30 seconds without
making a face and remember guys you have
to suck on them to get Max sourness
whether you make it to 30 seconds or not
you can choose to swallow them or if you
don't want them all right it's not
complicated I know how the [__]
challenge works you put it in you suck
you spit or you swallow
it's always the choice Dan uh Dan has a
timer right yeah I was just grabbing
that I'm gonna throw it up on well let's
let's go one at a time I mean I don't
think it's gonna take as long as like
the spicy chip would it be cool if I
went first I've been kind of stressed
about this let's see let's see Zach do
it and then we'll decide how to proceed
all right let's see Zach okay all right
wait wait you started when I put it in
my mouth right yes okay hold on hold on
hold on I can't see Zach on my preview
monitor oh well um right
three
so I have to put the uh timer up here
can you put on the other screen and cut
to it
yeah
if you give us a minute we could uh
maybe figure this out
so we put three in our mouth correct
okay got
nervous
all right go ahead Zach okay
I'm not now cut to Zach okay okay I'm
just gonna I'll tell you when 30 seconds
pass we won't have it on show me the
gummies Zack
you got three yeah do you put three at
the same time you go like one two three
three all at once all once okay 30
seconds no face okay face three two
you're good I'm going in okay
he's chewing even are you chewing you
mad man okay
so far so good he's swirling it around
no problem right Zach no problem for
Zach
Amanda
you're gonna eat it
is there anything Pleasant about it
wow Zach just ate those like gushers I
did I'll do three more
okay
these are really good I'm excited FaZe
rug whatever you said well that was 30
seconds so I think he he easily passed
that I think you are this Tower
climactic are they even sour yeah that's
the
what's going on like this is not
I'll let you guys decide this this this
challenge is a dud man I'm pretty good
with sour though so all right is it
sweet is it have a nice flavor
all different flavors
the [__] all right it was not good at
sour I'm not good with sour why don't
you go next then
it's [__] [__] give me oh pretty
good ooey gooey so if I if I get through
this then this this whole challenge is
phase the [__] down
or what are the calories on these three
I gotta check I mean this this is this
has sugar in it it's got gelatin it's 20
calories first oh [__] I didn't even
think about that
oh [__] I shouldn't have said that
ingredient oh
is there gelatin
I don't see
I don't see gelatin
wow they actually made him without
gelatin dude my guy dude I was ready to
I like this the presentation is lovely I
think he did a great job I like it what
did they use for instead of gelatin I
don't see anything if it's not sour
though it's like
all right here I go I'll tell you if
it's sour you'll tell you could tell if
I do it sure [__] I hate sour [__] so
much
all right clock started
you sucking on them
you look a little bit upset that's 15
halfway there
and
and you'll be at 30 right now
I was 30.
the spitter
oh wow you don't like it oh bad
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah I mean I listen I'm not good with
sour and I did that
yeah so I mean you looked pretty
affected
ugh you ah why what about this how we're
doing look
what about it yeah is it the the
puckering
yeah I like nothing about it okay fair
enough nothing about it I mean I like a
little sour candy but like like Warheads
do you like Warheads or no no see I love
[__] I love Warheads yeah
is anyone else bad with sour damn why
don't you do this this is your challenge
just chew them and eat them like Zach
just chew them and eat them yeah all six
all six I'm gonna do three I did six I
have a sore throat okay this is probably
not a good idea to be doing at all so
all right go ahead go easy on me all
right hold on let me get my own I'm
gonna do the stopwatch give him a good
suck a little chill
people are mad at us because we drank
the neutralizer first they think they
ruined it oh chill I don't know
well I didn't okay Dan I haven't had the
neutralizer yet so uh I'm going in raw
baby I'm hitting it raw
all right here we go
Dan is chewing he is
he is so far not reacting although it
seems he's fighting some kind of
squinting action in his eyes
is that right Dan are you fighting a
squinting action
yeah
he's he
munching
oh I see you're fine he's fine you're
fine Dan
yes that's really [__] sour I don't
know like what the [__] are you talking
about
actually a little nervous to do it
maybe Zach did do the new I think you're
the sour King dude because you like that
barely affected you
um
I took a little baby sip of it
wouldn't that make it worse we can
neutralize first it's like give me six
more I don't even know what this
neutralizer is is this even scientific
or is it just yeah a bunch of [__]
well it says with the ingredients let's
see magnesium calcium
natural flavors
um this is gross all different sounds
like a sports drink yeah almost like
standard chip
give me give me six more I got no
problem doing it again people say you're
not supposed to chew them that's true
you're supposed to and suck all right go
ahead Dan do another one all right
three suck em good I'm sucking this time
I'm doing nothing but sucking no chewing
talk to me baby what's up
can you get the rock to if the rock is
turned on by what Dan is doing at this
moment sucks
not the Rock
Ben
is sucks
Dan is sucking hard
I don't think Dan's gonna have any
problem swirling around
God I love her
my mouth is watering come here I won't
eat them
Dan is uh done bro it's not that bad
yeah it's not that bad
sorry sorry rug sorry to disappoint I
mean it's out
it's sour it's very sour pretty sure I
just we all just got rug pulled
close to Warhead for me personally yeah
I feel like popping a full mouth
like three or four Warheads right would
be more intense than this right
man we got played I feel like a little
bit I'm gonna slap mine and I think I
think the hard candy aspect makes it
harder go ahead so love you got three in
there you're already over it
Love's just hungry yeah love just yeah
I think the WarHeads are a bit worse
there it is
thank you FaZe rug
I'm gonna try now that I've done two
rounds I'm gonna try the neutralizer and
see if it works
Dan is neutralizing you don't have to
time me but I'm just gonna try it
curiosity with you I mean yeah if you
put something horrific in your mouth
sure it'll make me forget
what'd you do did you do it EB
B yeah you got it in you got three in
there
this man's sucking the problem we're
faced with here today is that three
Warheads would be way way harder
I think so I kind of feel like the king
is already out there hey I think that's
a face maybe he's been losing for yeah
the vector it's it's affecting him to be
honest I I'm pretty sure I cheated
because I I just kept I mean I was
sucking but I kept it in one spot
that's okay
you've got to play the game sometimes
okay
thank you
thank you we're just all Alpha as [__]
here in the office handle I'm not I
think I would really like this if I ate
one by one
yeah I mean it's not about candy you
know they should just make this a candy
bro even sour skittles are worse than
that [__]
what I think this was more sour than
sour skittles really but I but I agree
less than Warheads all right well there
it is guys uh
turns out it's not that sour
I'm gonna start making a little
disappointing a little enjoyable you
know experience good good packaging good
marketing
yeah except that the product's not good
you know what I mean maybe it's for kids
oh that's sour but still Warheads I used
to buy Warheads at the convenience store
for five cents
throw them in
let's go ahead like covered in an acid
like citric acid cam is sucking so good
suck em cam yeah
you know what I have a new product
the world's spiciest chip I'm gonna put
a Dorito nacho cheese spicy in there
people be like it's not that spicy but
the chip is good I'm like yeah oh yeah
it's nacho cheese Doritos
no problem Ian says
cam is having no issues over there right
yeah
sorry sorry bro people keep accusing you
of cheating Ethan
okay I said I cheated I mean look I you
know
I said I kept I I literally said what I
did what do you mean what do you
accusing me of I said it
um we said if it doesn't feel like
battery acid burning my mouth I don't
want it yeah I feel you and that wasn't
quite to this level I could you know
what I could do let's bottle battery
acid and then sell that you gotta suck
on that okay
I will say the neutralizer instantly
kills All Stars I I did I I would agree
that it worked wait we should have read
the reviews you guys on purpose
one-up sour challenge by murdered
just buy some Warheads 18 a box oh
he's up we got rug we got another phase
I'm gonna say it
can I say it called scam
I wouldn't
you wouldn't go that far it's not us it
was over promise I mean it's it's
overgrown overpriced
you guys got scammed capitalism beat me
again that's what this review is good
the candy didn't taste bad
though not good either and the new
trailer [__] was pretty tasty sick [__]
bad it was not very sour at all
it's not even worthy of being called a
challenge Sour WarHeads are way more
sour than this that's what I'm saying if
you don't like sour stuff yes it'll be
sour but I found these to be a joke some
Warheads taste better also I would argue
well there's a reward at the middle too
they're they're made yeah nice little
burst of sweet you know what kid I was
I would take the WarHeads to the sink
and wash off the sour patch [__]
at least half of it and then I'd be like
oh yeah Warheads
I'd be like wow it's so it's so good
when you get to the middle you scammed
okay scammed my own mouth I guess
sour but not a challenge I don't think
one single person liked this not sour
not a crazy thing rug if you you had a
brilliant idea like why would you
half-ass it with this dumb [__] yeah
this could have been the next Hot Chip
I thought it was yeah dumb
nah rug why would you do this to us rug
come up rug my boy the one phase member
I thought would never betray me
but now you've sold me this product from
sour
it's not even [__] sour man
[Music]
we should make our own brand
if you look at um if you look at the
Al Pacino's resting face it's more sour
[Music]
Dinero De Niro
if you look at my son's face it's more
sour
oh we hit dinner I wasn't it was Al
Pacino
yes yeah wait what do you what stop
forget it
move on
all right well that's a bust you know I
was thinking like damn we're gonna sell
a ton of these for him but I wouldn't
recommend buying it 20 bucks
sour gummy challenge I mean it works for
me intensity of the challenge was that a
20 challenge for you baby
what's that was that worth the twenty
dollar shot no no but I guess he's maybe
younger audience being into it what's a
challenge we can make
what's the uh I mean they're spicy and
Extreme Sour Whatever salt extreme yeah
oh that's like the Swedish candy yeah is
that fun do people like salty [__] yeah
[__] candy of all time and I just
give them a salt Cube here's pure salts
bison Swedish candy spicy fecal fish
though everything combined yeah every
day I personally did love fire uh uh
what were they called Fireballs those I
[__] with those are good the red uh
the red hard candy balls that were super
spicy you didn't wash those off in the
sink even no I did those ones those were
my [__] oh yeah the cinnamon one right
Fireball is right I remember these those
are also like five cents from the
goddamn gas station
God damn did you guys ever do the thing
with um the cinnamon gum where you lick
the wrapper of the package and you put
it on your forehead and then it burns
your what no it leaves a big uh red mark
on your head from cinnamon gum from big
red gum yeah from that uh What uh
that's I don't know I guess just me here
I've got one what about um
what if I package like a
let's say
a little [__] it I don't have a good
idea what about like fart candy oh yeah
what I was thinking is I was remembering
that Nathan Fielder episode where he did
the uh poop flavored um
yogurt that was the first episode yeah
yeah
Ethan's Pepto challenge what if we
somehow got a who the [__] trying poop
I challenge you to taste this poop
flavored candy yeah and what if it don't
poop don't make a face for like a minute
you know
don't throw up do not swallow it
and it's not an option you will get sick
and try not to swallow either
right
like here's here's my neutralizer it's
bleach
[Laughter]
all right let's move on quickly from the
sour Fiasco it's a fiasco
[Music]
Spanish
is that a Spanish word
Fiasco
why are you asking that because it's a
great word I just love it and but why
because it sounds like Fiesta you think
it's Spanish it's Italian Fiasco it
sounds okay it's Italian oh it is
okay hey it's a Fiat it's a fiasco
Fiasco comes from an Italian term that
means to make a bottle
my producer Dan he's sitting here asking
about fiascos and in the process he's
created one himself oh come on
Zach not there
all right we're moving on
so we it's too late
let's see Twitter's rebranding as X
so uh Crowder the Crowder story
and uh The Tick Tock plastic surgeon who
got a banned from practicing because she
was doing tick tocks while her parent
her patients were out oh my God what do
we like let's uh let's do the Crowder
thing or Tate War Room leaks
that's too in-depth okay
just because your call is in 30 minutes
so
I could see us
going way further down the rabbit hole
well the Crowders one is good and I I
take any opportunity I can to just [__]
all over this freak let's do it let's do
Crowder
so more ex-staffers
are talking to the media about what a
degenerate loser
uh Crowder is and sex possible sex
criminal as well here's the headline
watch it uh exclusive Stephen Crowder
sent photos of his genitals and
exchanged drugs and super creepy
workplace
he needs Joma dude yeah
he is in Texas
crowders-based in Texas so this is it
says X staffers say this is this is
multiple people yes
let's see uh
let's the the first half of the article
re reiterates what we previously heard
about him pulling his dick out all the
time
and uh his admiration for male intimacy
aka the Spartans wait is that a real
thing yeah so he I guess in a uh
a Bible study group that he uh organized
at at work
I guess company mandated Bible study
um
that's not legal I I don't know if it
was actually mandated or if it was just
like an extracurricular well that's an
interesting place to try to meet a dude
uh at Bible study
sounds like a like a smut novel or
something
um but yeah I guess uh he uh one of his
favorite favorite Bible verses was about
how uh
men would get close to each other's
descendants right AKA their uh testicles
so I was onto something with the Spartan
call out I did I thought that was
interesting when I read this detail
because you had specifically mentioned
that one when he uh
got ambushed on our show all right let
me just read this so now the Fallout
after all the previous exposes he's been
through on the divorce and workplace
misconduct have threatened to derail the
enormously popular show that once landed
himself once I mean this was a few
months ago this man could have walked
away with 50 million cool
guaranteed from the daily wire now he's
on Rumble I don't even know if he has a
partnership with them they're in his
episodes have like 250 000 views now
yeah his viewership has dropped off
quite a bit from his heyday
uh
media mediaite spoke with five four oh
five that's damning five former show
staffers and one source close to Crowder
again I don't know what that means One
Source close to Crowder what is that uh
it'll become relevant later and um
and Sam Cedar had an interesting theory
about who the source close to Crowder is
but it'll make more sense later so it's
five staffers and apparently a bestie
under the condition of a nanamidity due
to fear of retaliation who described the
workplace Rife with bullying alarm
alarming and unprecedented uh
unpredictable Behavior as well as lewd
sexual workplace misconduct sounds like
a utopian work environment
sounds like a Libertarian worker
actually sounds like this guy might
belong in jail well
uh pivot time
earlier this month after repeated
suspensions letter of crowder D Camp
from YouTube well done
moved his 5.8 million subscribers to
rumble less regulated but smaller
alternative yada yada the show's
audience has dwindled to the point where
his last five shows have averaged 288
000 views which of course is a lot but
his show used to push major numbers man
50 million I remember around the time
that we ambushed him uh his live streams
on YouTube would have over a million
views within 24 hours of each episode so
which is that's that's big that's that's
quite fast it takes us several days to
hit a million if we hit a million in 24
hours that's like a Monster episode yeah
so this guy had it all
except apparently a happy marriage a
wife that loved him right kids that
loved him a nice working environment uh
right a good state of mind yeah right
parent well-adjusted uh live parents
that love him lack of self-loathing
human decency yeah right but he had it
all yeah he had everything but but all
that and apparently he had it all but um
Percocets which he was looking for right
for those everything but enough perk has
said no
that doesn't work for me either it's
crazy how much that no sounds like the
good doctor no it's like not that far
play it back to back no yeah hold on I
gotta group one together okay sorry
sorry I don't think they sound alike
no
no no no
okay yeah
then Crowder
no all right one former lateral Crowder
employee told uh mediaite that during
his time on the show he received
unsolicited unsolicited sexually graphic
texts that included Crowder's genitals
those texts and images were reviewed by
mediaite okay that's a crime watch it I
mean if you're sending people
unsolicited dick pics that's a crime
yeah never mind the boss employee
relationship like holy [__]
that's that's that is so unhinged yeah
and the moment we I didn't even think
Harvey Weinstein was sending people dick
pics
nope I mean he was up to things don't
get me wrong right in the moment we
dismissed it as sort of a frat boy humor
in hindsight it's super creepy and felt
groomish
rumor-ish
it always felt like child uh childish
behavior in the moment they said in the
moment we dismissed it as frat boy humor
in hindsight it's super creepy
yeah those aren't mutually exclusive
things at all it turns out Frat Boys are
pretty creepy yeah no those are like you
kind of just said this you're talking
about the guys who like Haze people to
death
are you saying that they're creepy and
weird it's a Vibe right now yeah milk
boy yeah exactly bro I'm gonna Haze you
you have to walk across this uh field
full of glass while chugging an eighth
of Jack Daniel I'm gonna send it and I'm
gonna spank you while you do it and then
I'm tying this brick to your dick and
throwing it off the side of this
building right and then you're gonna be
one of us dude
it always felt like childish behavior in
the moment
uh that then fell predatory in hindsight
he explained like he was always testing
people's Comfort levels with that kind
of behavior because he was the boss
though and he had no accountability it
just continued to happen there was no
one trusted to to complain to that's not
a good either no HR Stephen Stephen
it's probably his dad
oh that's what so his dad is there with
him yeah so presumably his dad is
watching him
sexually uh harassed all of his
employees his dad see it on these emails
you secretly see Dad BCC dad check it
out
Darren uh Crowder friend of the show
yeah
should we reach out to Darren for a
comment well maybe I should send him
this send him a picture send him a
picture of my dick yeah what are you
talking he's called in before yeah he
had a great voice he's called in oh he
did have a great voice you're right
Cameron wait when did his dad call in
uh
[Music]
the the days of impersonating people is
over since keemstar got a strike yeah
for impersonating what was it his
girlfriend so lame that was your first
time on the show it was so good thank
you
came in with the bang yeah that was my
first time on the show too is that wow
put you guys right to work first time on
the show banned for a week yeah it's
like gee thanks
no you did great uh in addition to
receiving unwanted sexual text messages
the former employee alleged that Crowder
habitually exposed himself to other male
staffers a claim backed up by two other
sources now Crowders in his mid-30s I'm
assuming he's close to my age
and yeah and to be in the state of mind
too
be taking out my dick
he's 36 he's uh him and I are almost the
exact same age
so put yourself in the mentality where
you're walking around taking your dick
out to everybody in the office that
seems pretty wild
if if one of you guys was doing that I
probably would have to file a police
report
that would be so insane
uh we're having a problem Ethan uh Zach
has been uh taking his dick out at the
office
this out
you would never the [__] meat sandwich
dude I ain't right right
bringing your dick in like a hot dog bun
you hungry bro I [__] got you bro
wait who did that who did it was from a
movie where he had his dick and a hot
dog bun and put like mustard on it no no
no what
somebody did that for real here yeah
it's someone not here no no no no no no
no one in the crew but someone that
we've had on the show or been in our
vicinity Steve will do it that sounds
like a steep it was Joey's salads oh
wait Joey salads did do lots of Dick
play he put his dick dick in a hot dog
and put mustard
very similar politics to Stephen Crowder
as well you know what interesting I'm
pretty sure that those two guys might
have a lot in common yeah maybe they can
get together and pee in each other's
mouths
[Laughter]
oh man Crowder as [__] right now
let's see
um
uh in regards to exposing himself in
general to my knowledge he only exposed
himself to male staffers
oh that's sweet oh okay that was fun he
protected the women's uh yeah Grace and
chastity
it happened all the time it was a
regular occurrence it usually happened
when he was in a really good mood sort
of a manic mood
so while we were all disgusted by it and
it never was never welcomed it was
preferable to him being in a bad mood
and how he treated people in that state
wow wow what a guy oh my God no good
days yeah pick your option either he's
an [__] screaming at everybody or
he's just it's a swinging his dick
around it's a dick date everybody
packing your dick between your legs so
he this is an act of Jubilation for him
yeah he's feeling good he's like here's
my dick everybody
foreign
[__] me what a crazy mentality to be in
I mean you're the boss man you're making
millions of dollars don't at least at
least let them
maintain some self-respect
the dick
Stephen never explained it he said we
never talked about it it would just
happen and everyone would either throw
out a fake uncomfortable laugh or show
clear disgust which Stephen interpreted
as his reward for what he did
he's this he's this guy
he's the Flasher with the [__] trench
coat right he gets off on disgusting
them it seems like
the more disgusted everyone seemed the
more pleasure he seemed to get from it
it's like he couldn't understand that we
weren't in on his joke
wow
it's phenomenal
response to a quest for comment lateral
Crowder CEO Gerald Morgan Jr there's a
CEO
a CEO uh yeah
okay seems a little bit over the top
well bro uh let's see he said
well louder with Crowder does not
provide details on personal private
medical matters Medical
or Personnel issues it is important to
note that many of these claims are
missing context clear misrepresentations
or outright falsehoods okay let's talk
specifically about
the showing the dick
is that missing context
dude they were asking to see it you're
missing the context oh uh Gerald by the
way is we we're familiar with him he's
one of the co-hosts
let me see this [__] this guy
oh that guy yeah yeah so that's him he's
not the CEO
he's just he just puts that there so for
like the paperwork that guy's just
another [__] boy perhaps hey Gerard how
many times have you seen Crowder's dick
you're missing the contest what's the
con the context is that I like it
okay
another source close to Crowder also
said they witnessed him expose himself
to male staffers in the office but
chalked it up to childish behavior what
is wrong with this world man me too just
skipped over the male workplace
men are just like
I don't think the message got to us yet
I've you know it's like practically
sounds like all the dudes just walk
around with their zipper down in their
dicks out right just they work they
stand up their dicks out
they get water their dicks out
they're washing the dishes their dick is
out
where would we be without dicks out
I have personally witnessed that on one
occasion they said my personal Theory
is that he's a man child and just thinks
it's funny like boys in Middle School
playing pranks on each other in the
locker room that to me seems to be his
mentality could it be a power move
possibly they said he does virtually
nothing that a grown man should do for
himself wash his own laundry prepare his
own food buy his own groceries yeah his
wife that's his wife's job we know that
that's women work
most of the time someone else does all
that for him so he's like a child that
needs to be taken care of and his humor
reflects that type of childish behavior
for example when he uh did a mock
reenactment of killing George Floyd well
that was really fun and childish
yeah watch it goofing around
just goofing around so uh that last
paragraph which you'll notice comes
immediately after the statement from uh
Gerald the CEO Sam Cedar when I was
watching him react to this uh
he strongly suspects that that Source
close to Crowder is Gerald and he just
wanted that part off the Record yo that
would be down and dirty though well
that's the thing though that if you read
that paragraph that's his job it's kind
of negative on him right but I mean it
also he is sort of minimizing it in that
paragraph you know what I mean because
he says
right
okay so we don't know that for sure but
Sam pointed out that in the other
instances of talking about uh
the employee everything else was
ex-employee
and then that part was the uh Source
close to Crowder so that that sounds
like somebody that still works for him
and they do have a statement from him in
this same article that's pretty tricky
on the journalist part because they have
a statement and then they're also
protecting his identity it's weird
well he might have told them uh listen
I'll talk frankly to you but it has to
be off the Record
kind of thing I don't think he did very
well defending him I'm just admitting
that it's happened on several occasions
is basically just this is probably
[__] fed up with the two you know but
that's his job
yeah I don't think he's got a 50 million
dollar deal lined up although neither
does Crowder at this point
I think Crowder might lose everything
from 50 million dollar guaranteed over
three years to maybe just
destitute
divorced obviously she took the kids
yeah I'd love that addicted to perks
God I feel so bad for him that his life
is going down the drain yeah
couldn't happen to a nicer guy
definitely Why did Why did Why does
why is it always the good ones that get
the worst misfortune
why is it that the good are always the
ones that die young so [__] stupid
bro what has Crowder done to deserve
this karmatic
Justice yeah Mischief just think about
it dude
was it the time he uh
mock murdered George Floyd no no no
talked about black Farmers that [__] was
so crazy I can't even
um right right
was it the time he
blew cigar smoke and his pregnant wife's
mouth
no wasn't that
um
maybe it was the time that he uh shoved
somebody at a uh Union rally and um
deceptively edited it so that the
retaliation seemed like uh
like it was an unprovoked attack no it
wasn't that no wasn't that
could it have been the sexual crimes
he's been committing basically for
decades no no it couldn't be that
it could just be that life is unfair
and uh
it's always the good ones damn remember
the chat pointed out yeah he's gonna
lose the one car the divorce no the man
has no walk no walk that Texas Heat
he's probably got a few uh dollars
stocked away though for well evidently
not hard times I only have one car
dude this man has no kids no wife no car
no Riz I had no idea this was going to
happen no [__] no money
what are you doing man
another she was a stand-up guy yeah well
thought again think again think again
another former employee said incidents
of genital exposure in the workplace
were so routine that they became almost
remarkable
uh unremarkable the guy just talked
about it amongst themselves and I don't
want to say it because it became normal
but it did become less of a big deal
that's wow
I mean that is kind of grooming right if
you're just like yeah I'm just my boss
just shows me his dick that's just part
of the job
and then next he's gonna be like hey
touch it
go ahead
I know you wanna I don't know
here is um actually [__] so he actually
even did a potentially to Ben Shapiro as
well
Ben looks not that upset about it
frankly
um
the sapphire said Crowder freaker
frequently remarked that men used to be
more physically intimate with each other
and then would reference a passage from
the Bible where Abraham's servant put
his hand on Abraham's inner thigh to be
closer to Abraham's descendants his
balls um amazing he used to tell this
story frequently you know gay
yeah
what the at Bible study
does God know you're gay
I think he does I think God knows
allegations of crowd are revealing his
genitalia in the workplace were first
reported by the New York Post
interestingly a conservative uh
publication right
uh right-leaning
and response Crowder mocked allegations
during a skit show
did I we see that wait I want to see
that
uh
uh yeah I think we actually did right I
did not see this
I think we actually did react to it he
responded in the form of skit well at
least it wasn't a ukulele
how to read it all right play the damn
thing Rumble are you loading or what
it's not Rumble it's just like this
website's media player just uh try
refreshing it seems like it's bugged out
I really want to see this video
God damn it well here
I can it says May 2nd maybe you guys can
find it
okay
thank you
thank you so much
how did you become gay
oh wait is it working now
it's not loading
I mean there it is
to uh multiply
uh let's see where was I
talking about uh
male Intimacy in Bible study yes I miss
it I miss the time when male intimacy
was abrahamic as [__]
let's see um
yeah here it is uh
different ex-staffer said
okay hold on so there's a case to be
made he was grooming employees
um a former employee said Stephen may
excuse some of that saying he was
friends with some of the employees but
then again draw some questions there are
power dynamics that play regard
regardless of how friendly you are with
the staff that sounds pretty [__]
woke to me dude what's going on over at
Crowder's office space we're talking
about power dynamics and [__] and also
just don't send your penis in a message
it's gross okay listen
lower your expectations
you're asking for too much
what are you going to go on strike loser
a different ex staffer said Crowder
would often make uncomfortable comments
during a men's only Bible study let's go
this was the part you just read okay
skipping that
uh allegation of crowd revealing is
genitals in the workplace were first I
read that
um
yeah Crowder's alleged penchant for exit
exhibitionism and angry outbursts are
only a portion of the inappropriate
workplace Behavior described by sources
who worked for the YouTube Star
multiple former staffers and a source
close writer claimed the conservative
Firebrand would offer and ask staffers
for prescription drugs like Klonopin hmm
which is basically Xanax
as well as cannabis gummies and opiates
like percocet that's wild
yo anyone got a perks
any of you guys got Xanax or perks going
spare
it's awesome
Steven was known for passing out
prescription drugs fairly freely oh
that's that's a good boss that's a good
boss that's super generous that's fire
ah
it's surprising the employees when your
boss is offering and or asking for
things like that however because the
work environment is so crazy employees
end up getting desensitized to the point
where when things like that occur
it almost seems normal
almost
it's almost just seem yeah it's not
until you actually step away for a bit
you realize how wrong these types of
things are
former employee received General photos
from Crowder shared a similar sentiment
about working with the YouTube Star
we've often debated this it's like any
abusive relationship when it's good it
can be really fun
most people enjoy the work itself but
when it's bad it's really bad
but over time you become so numb to it
they don't see how messed up the place
is until they get out
did I get the sketch you did maybe you
just dropped it yes I'm dying to see
this
is our time stamp uh yeah if he said at
51 30. when it comes to the things you
love most oh wait this is good getting
in the way
are your favorite indulgences followed
by needless feelings of crippling guilt
Batman bad do you find yourself not
getting the same Joy from your once
favorite pastimes it may not be your
fault you may be suffering from chronic
mild to moderate
but awesome so fun you know he's so
funny
that's the worst part about this is
pushing boundaries it's just a great
comedic mind has gone to waste yeah
you're not alone it is estimated that 50
to 65 percent of Americans suffer from
moderate to severe fat goodness the good
news is lorcasarin can help in a recent
clinical trial Lord casser reduced
fatness and its symptoms by over aren't
they on Rumble why are they going to
censor the improved weight
you know he thinks cursing is uh racism
is fine there's an artistic choice or a
directorial choice if you will all right
5130 let's go to that
see
all right so in response to these
allegations of him showing his dick to
everybody he responded with this
he brought out in the case just to be
clear
well and you're actually forgetting one
it's just you oh yes well that's true
and which means by the way you can uh
leave a comment down below I forgot yes
Stephen wait this man's wearing a Jesus
is risen change my mind sure
I I don't think I'll be able to change
the mind of that one buddy I'm with you
Jesus up he's up
[Applause]
he's Jesus
oh boy we're waiting for him okay uh
yeah
yeah Sam oh my God she's getting in very
sorry but um I have something to discuss
with you oh god oh right okay
[Music]
Okay so if you're doing a sketch
maybe just explain who the character is
in the dialogue
because this is just really bad leave a
comment down below come back to the show
H.R Sam
[Music]
what is this a [__] fighting game oh
my God she's getting in very sorry but
um I have something to discuss with you
oh God all right okay
[Music]
that was so pointless all right Sam you
do know sanformation you do know that
we're live right yeah pull the
microphone you're an HR guy you're not
an audio Guy come on all right I am
aware of that and I am sorry but I've
got a line out the door
um with um and fractions that have
happened inside this office can we just
hit we can't just do this as a meeting
outside right now no it just can't wait
this might be ukulele level
you have a list of infractions that have
taken place in this office goodness
sorry Steven but this has to be
addressed okay um all right the other
day everything you're about to by the
way the Spartan thing is gone
I wonder if that was me um I'd like to
take credit for that say has actually
been spoken in this office yes that is
correct oh boy okay so these are all and
and what's the punishment right go go
just yeah so the other day Gary said
quote I have never met a Russian I that
I liked Gary did you actually say that I
did Stephen I'll be honest I'm sorry all
right well okay so we don't right I
don't remember that being in the
complaints uh people uh lodged I
appreciate it all right okay that's like
disgusting like the way he's doing it
Stevie crowdy it's so over enunciated it
makes me feel so icky
like just pay attention just keep your
eye on it keep your ear on it but he's
rushing but yeah it doesn't matter you
can't say that it's wrong to hate sure
all right that's his dad so his dad most
definitely has seen him dick his dick
out all right well okay so we don't
appreciate it all right okay Sam we got
that's really not that bad but he's
Russian but yeah it doesn't matter you
can't say that it's wrong to hate sure
all right Sam okay Kim said when in
doubt quote blame the clintons well okay
Kim that's not dude for crying out
really okay but you're accused of
showing people your dick
what is it
you know what I mean
like sexual harassment exposing yourself
so let's talk about
sorry Stephen you did say that all right
well look people say things in an office
these are minor infractions I think so I
mean yeah okay and then I would love if
you just like and then eight former
employees allege that you exposed your
genitals to them well uh you know boys
will be boys I mean you know who has it
who doesn't do that
toolman said
so we want to talk about this Jewish guy
that steals everyone's money did you say
that yeah I probably this sounds like me
I mean that sounds kind of [__] up
yeah I need to talk about this Jewish
guy who's stealing everybody's money
that does sound like a good HR moment
that actually is something that you said
yeah okay let's not he's Jewish let's
not do that and let's talk about Sam yes
okay all right and now now there's this
newspaper article out this morning where
um it says quote Crowder was known to
expose his genitals to stuff yeah yeah
we'll do yes just wait
I mean that did happen what are you
talking about the Terminator 2 sketch no
but at the time you only had five
employees and they were all male well
yeah I know but that was so what
and they all were sick of seniors dick
bro what's this what is this Terminator
two sketch he's talking about I don't
know but apparently he has dick out
which I would love to see
he has to go back in time to show John
Connors the only person in this office
who's seen my dick is Ian
right yeah that did it and I plan to
keep it at just that yeah maybe you
should explain for newer viewers I mean
I thought we told the story recently but
it's pretty good I mean I gave Ian my
camera to record so you want to tell it
Ian
no you go ahead I I just meant clarified
that that was a mistake that was not
intentional and it was in footage that
you had recorded Terminator sketch it
was yeah everybody remembers the
Terminator kit and he gave it to Ian to
edit and forgot he didn't remove the
part where yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah well now they're the ET ones
uh through the corn fields where we had
to run naked yeah naked in that one yeah
we were naked in that one too good one
that was the night though was it gay
Captain America because what happened is
the cold the the onesie didn't fit so we
just had to make it a nosy and there was
no
um well now that there are ladies here
we have to run things differently oh
they just skimmed right over that I we
heard you were showing your genitals
they they did this where they're like
did you were you making jokes okay and
Crowder were you exposing your genitals
hmm okay
there it is what more can I say
oh he was about to show his dick to the
HR oh that was yeah cool thing I clicked
off
well they don't show it but that that
was the uh climax of this uh oh that is
actually what happens yeah yeah that was
the finale of the sketch okay I actually
want to see that then
let's see your car TV
55 what was it
well it started at uh 51.
how about what are you talking about two
sketch three or four minutes into it at
the time you only had five employees and
they were all male well yeah I know but
that was a turtle that's so funny like
yeah dude you could show your dick to
dudes it's fine if
yeah okay
Steven why would you even want to film
this
like
come with me if you want to learn oh my
God oh my God
dude you can do
Arnold Schwarzenegger
and as Terminator and so many different
spots I have never seen one person
choose that one to do the impersonation
okay of course yes many people saw my
balls well yeah but
because annuities wouldn't fit you
couldn't do it yeah right yeah you have
a large posterior yes exactly okay
that's [__] gross Gerald what the
[__] are we talking okay Gerald
that is disgusting Gerald
that is honestly so vile and there were
also times where we play this about the
ball game yeah well uh we need to stay
on topic as well okay continuing with
the infractions Riley said quote they're
going back to this okay I mean the game
uh here it was right there
right there
is that your testicle yeah it is oh
my God there's a happiness
his dad thought it was hilarious
wow
yeah so it's uh 3 30 by the way right
now
how long we've been going
for two and a half hours shame
shame that's shame let's see if there's
anything else I'll hit on real fast I
mean the call is at 3 45. you lied
uh let's see pulling the dick out
the article also backs up Steven's
rumored attraction to men different next
staffers said Crowder would off to make
them uncomfortable comments during a
men's only Bible study held we talked
about that Jefferson crowded frequently
marked that men used to be more physical
we've talked about that and we got it
all we got it all baby okay
can you can you reach out to Crowder's
dad and just see if they have any perks
I'm just I'm just looking for sure
enough to get me through the week for
sure yeah
I'll pay top dollar
all right guys we got to cut it short
today
um because I got to talk to the doctor
I've been waiting for a long time for
this call
and I don't want to miss it because I
waited like a month
yeah
okay I was gonna do Howie's podcast
tomorrow
he said let's not do it oh because he he
doesn't [__] with that yeah no you were
right to tell him yeah I'm not gonna
read it he ain't he ain't about them
germs understandably
child
child yeah I'm glad I I would have
[__] his whole life up on if I went
there and was coughing and stuff so
I respect him too much he's Howie he's
how you know he's America's uncle
all right so then I will have do an
episode tomorrow uh new plan
tomorrow we'll be here for see you next
Tuesday for members who I love our
members thank you guys so much love them
people are saying stay on a mute I can
do that I mean I'm I'm definitely open
to that it's probably a bad idea though
there's gonna be like 30 minutes of dead
air potentially which is not necessarily
the most entertaining yeah
yeah I better just call it
what am I going to do on what now with
my life
I'm sorry man I know
so sorry
I'm sorry about it it's not your fault
all right guys so we'll see you tomorrow
for members Wednesday we'll be back as
usual I love you all thank you for being
here the sour challenge was what a bust
Man Boss l l challenge too easy it's not
even worthy of a title now I was like
what was that the sour challenge [__]
you [__] you [__] you hey Zach give me
yeah
child pornography
I better I better relax to my throat's
starting to hurt and I think this is
getting me a little loopy Dan do you
feel anything
you have not passed it over here no I
mean from what you've been taking
because you've been hitting here no I
didn't I just hit this
oh do you want some I've been drinking
it straight from the bottle probably not
for comedic effect
it's all good and you have to drive soon
so maybe
that doesn't say you can't operate
Machinery oh it almost certainly does
really let me go let me check the back
this is just like crowd up first passing
around perks
we'll see
it says
uh
uh it says you get you get an ask a
doctor if you get nervous dizzy or
Sleepless uh yeah
it doesn't say anything about Machinery
dude okay I'm [__] going I got it all
right baby cheers about to get in my
crane [__]
cheers my dudes
[Music]
foreign